i think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style
tristan thompson is heading to boston to
play for the celtics
and now a source tells e.t khloe
kardashian is feeling
all the feels about it e.t source says
quote
tristan in boston is a difficult pill to
swallow for chloe
especially since she and tristan have
been doing so much better as a couple
and as a family lately chloe is
especially going through it but is doing
her best to keep her head up and stay
positive
i'm really just enjoying my life last
month the nba star's agent
confirmed to yahoo sports that tristan
agreed to a deal with the celtics after
nine seasons with the cleveland
cavaliers
the reported two-year deal is said to be
worth
19 million dollars
isn't that crazy and while a source
previously told et that chloe would not
be uprooting her life in la with the
couple's two-year-old daughter true
it seems like that plan might be
changing
quote she's not excited for the move for
her family's sake but she is for tristan
and his career
at this point they're planning to split
their time between la and boston
but it's still up in the air and there's
no definite answer since they're still
working on rebuilding their relationship
and trust
and while the couple works out the
logistics of the move the source says
that tristan
is continuing to be extra attentive to
his girls
and will do whatever it takes to keep
the family together and stronger than
ever
it's such a beautiful thing of course
tristan and chloe rekindled their
romance in august after more than a year
apart
at the time a source told et the couple
is back together and things have been
going really well
i'm just super happy and content the
athlete was previously involved in
multiple cheating scandals
including one with kylie jenner's former
bestie
jordan woods you know things happen and
of course i'm sorry
and fans can watch the couple's journey
to reconciliation
as it's playing out on keeping up with
the kardashians which will return to e
in 2021 for its 20th
and final season i 100
have a block up but who wouldn't like
every relationship i go into they're
always
disappointing and dumb so i have every
reason
to be guarded i have every reason to
have these
bricks up and layers and if somebody
cares enough
they will take those bricks down brick
by brick